[Aplausos]
olá aqui nesse lugar
eu venho falar como se falasse de alento
no como se estivesse morta porque na
morte que a história me coloca apesar de
eu não estar morta
eu venho falar de mim e de meu povo
mas eu trago comigo também as vozes de
cerca de 900 mil pessoas que pertencem a
306 povos diferentes e falam mais de 100
idiomas é muito não é quase nada porque
nós já fomos 9 milhões porque somos
vítimas do maior genocídio da história
da humanidade porque desde o dia 12 de
outubro de 1492
nós estamos sendo mortos desde esse dia
que é comemorado como a descoberta das
américas
a propósito na minha opinião ao invés de
américa eu prefiro abya yalá e tem outra
coisa e aí não é opinião um índio é
errado
o certo é indígena povo originário da
terra e no meu caso por i ou
simplesmente gente
quero começar contando um causo que se
passou comigo um tempo atrás
há alguns anos eu escrevo em um blog
textos a respeito do mundo indígena e é
muito comum que receba mensagens e certa
vez escreveu uma fotógrafa que queria
fazer o ensaio sobre as mulheres puri e
queria me ajuda ela me contou que na
cidade onde ela vivia foi feito um
trabalho de constelação e que através
desse trabalho ela descobriu que a
cidade em que ela nasceu foi construir
numa terra puri uma aldeia que foi
dizimada e por causa disso ela queria
fazer uma homenagem aos espíritos
ancestrais que haviam ali até esse
momento a proposta me parecia
interessante e eu quis saber mais a
respeito
foi aí que os problemas começaram ela me
disse que colocou um anúncio na internet
à procura de modelos mas que estava
tendo dificuldade até aquele momento só
apareceu uma moça que se identificou
como cury
mas ela não tinha o perfil que ela
procurava o que ela tinha traços de
negra
ela queria a minha ajuda para encontrar
mulheres dentro desse perfil
e esse perfil que ela buscava era de
mulheres que tivessem cara de índia
especialmente um cabelo preto longo e
liso para poder cortar uma franjinha e
ela queria também que eu explicasse pra
ela como são os trajes típicos do meu
povo para que ela pudesse caracterizar
essas mulheres não precisavam ser
mulheres puri poderiam ser de qualquer
povo aleatório desde que tivessem cara
de índio e ela disse que as fotos ela
gostaria de fazer uma locação de
natureza para poder tirar fotos que
pudessem fazer uma representação bem
fiel e ela quis saber a minha opinião
sobre a idéia dela havia tanto problema
nisso que ela me falou que eu não sabia
nem por onde começar isso que ela
chamava de representação fiel é falso e
é por causa desse tipo de representação
que o meu povo até hoje precisa lutar
para provar que está vivo mas pra que
vocês entendam isso eu preciso contar a
história do meu povo os puri o meu povo
tinha suas terras originárias na região
que hoje corresponde à parte dos estados
de minas gerais rio de janeiro espírito
santo terras essas muito ricas e
cobiçadas e que foram alvo de assassinos
sanguinários que nos livros de história
de vocês são chamados de bandeirantes
heróis e civilizadores deixa eu contar
uma coisinha respeito desses heróis
eu acho que todo mundo aqui já ouviu uma
expressão e talvez alguns também já têm
usado essa expressão para falar de uma
ancestral obscura da sua linha
genealógica
como sempre são obscuras as histórias
dos ancestrais que não são brancas
essa expressão diz o seguinte a minha
avó foi pega no laço ou então a minha
avó foi pega a dente de cachorro mas
você sabe o que essa expressão quer
dizer porque eu sei e eu daria tudo para
não saber mas acontece que eu sei
essa expressão quer dizer que as minhas
avós foram cassadas e estupradas e não
só as minhas avós todas as mulheres do
meu povo furo e não só as mulheres do
meu povo porque esse país que é chamado
brasil é fruto do estupro sistemático de
milhares de mulheres e do assassinato de
nações inteiras e quem dera eu tivesse
falando de uma história do passado eu
não tô isso está acontecendo agora agora
mesmo enquanto eu falo com você e eu sei
disso porque no dia 22 de junho de 2002
eu entrei para a maldita estatística que
diz que uma em cada quatro mulheres vai
ser vítima de violência sexual pelo
menos uma vez ao longo da sua vida
contém as mulheres em volta de vocês
uma duas três quatro uma duas três
quatro uma duas três quatro uma duas
três quatro
eu te pergunto se é possível respirar
sabendo disso mas eu precisei respirar e
as minhas avós também eu precisei
encontrar forças onde não existia
uma está sozinha e seguir adiante e não
eu não estou querendo dizer que o que
aconteceu comigo foi o mesmo que
aconteceu com elas porque fui com elas
foi muito pior
elas viram seus pais os seus maridos os
seus filhos sendo assassinados
elas viram as suas aldeias sendo
destruídas
elas foram escravizadas
elas foram obrigadas a guardar um mundo
inteiro dentro de se esperar esperar
esperar até que tivessem passado
gerações na esperança de quem sabe esse
mundo pudesse renascer isso do que eu
estou falando
era um empreendimento comercial
patrocinado pelo governo que pretendia
burlar a lei que proibia o tráfego
ultramarino de escravos
esse projeto escravizou mulheres
indígenas e os seus ventres e as obrigou
a ter filhos com negros escravizados
paraná serem filhos de escravos e
chamados negros da terra
isso também era feito para baratear a
mão de obra escrava porque era mais
barato produzir localmente do que
importar e havia também um outro
objetivo porque afinal de contas é
importante melhorar a raça porque como
diziam e até hoje dizem alguns
os silvícolas são preguiçosos e
indolentes para o trabalho então quem
sabe misturando negro pode nascer daí
uma coisa melhor
até porque na cabeça dos gestores desse
projeto índio era uma aberração sem alma
uma coisa atrasada da evolução fadada a
desaparecer e mais uma vez quem dera eu
tivesse falando do passado mas a verdade
é que até 1900
setenta ainda persistia mesmo na
academia
a idéia de que a identidade indígena era
transitórias
uma coisa que com o tempo ea mistura ia
se diluir claro à luz da civilização
iria nos iluminar como se nós não
tivéssemos a nossa própria noção de
civilização
só porque a nossa forma de ver o mundo
era diferente eles julgaram e nos
condenaram à morte
eles nos impediram de professar as
nossas crenças de falar a nossa língua
nos tiraram das nossas terras e no caso
específico do meu povo nos barreiros da
própria história porque na década de
1830 os registros históricos disseram
que os puri estavam extintos e nós até
hoje lutamos para reverter a noção desse
registro e vocês não sabem como é
cansativo tentar provar todos os dias
que se está vivo
é claro que nós não somos mais como nós
éramos antes mas nós somos aquele poder
poeira das estrelas filhos dos diamantes
e essa é nossa forma de dizer
resistência isso é tudo que nós queremos
seguir vivos apesar de tudo eu sempre
tive um enorme desconforto na minha vida
eu não cresci numa aldeia ea história
que eu aprendi foi toda esburacada e até
hoje essa história é cheia de fragmentos
e silêncios
eu não sabia quem eu era e era sempre
muito difícil me olhar no espelho não
saber quem era aquela que estava ali
para tentar resolver eu fui estudar
primeiro eu fiz direito depois de
antropologia o mestrado e agora o
doutorado e eu me encontrei foi no meio
do movimento indígena que finalmente eu
pude dizer quem eu sou e eu eu sou
indígena e foi por isso que naquele dia
eu disse pra aquela fotógrafa que aquela
ideia que ela
tinha de homenagem era tão errada e até
mesmo ofensiva porque é exatamente esse
tipo de representação que me
invisibilizar m apaga todos os dias
é por causa desse tipo de coisa que eu
tenho que escutar quando estou nas
cidades volta para a aldeia
mesmo eu que não tem uma aldeia para
voltar é por causa desse tipo de
representação que eu sou tratada como
invasora na cidade
como se não fosse a cidade que nos
invadiu é por causa desse tipo de
representação que eu sou questionada
quanto a minha identidade
não só pela minha aparência
por eu falar bem por escrever direito o
trabalhar direitinho e cumprir as minhas
tarefas é por causa desse tipo de
representação que as mulheres indígenas
são tratadas como fetiche sexual é por
causa desse tipo de representação que os
meus trajes são considerados fantasia
mas não são
isso é identidade identidade não tem a
ver com aquilo que eu visto tem a ver
com que eu sou você quer homenagear a
memória das mulheres indígenas que foram
massacradas sabe o tipo de homenagem que
eu gostaria de prestar as minhas avós
eu gostaria de poder encontrá las
principalmente aquela que tinha 11 anos
e que segundo dizem
apesar de ser uma menina ainda era tão
brava e tão forte que precisou de dez
homens para ser subjulgada eu gostaria
de poder olhar nos olhos dela e dizer as
palavras que eu esperei nove anos para
poder ouvir as palavras que me
libertaram das minhas concorrentes me
permitirão seguir em frente não foi sua
culpa não foi sua culpa veio pra mim
encontro místico com minha mãe do corda
chamon que se envolveu em meu corpo e me
disse que era hora de parar de morrer
tanto e que me disse que era hora de
trocar de pele e começa a renascer mas
sabe que não é justo não é justo esperar
nove anos
não é justo ter que ser um encontro
místico e é por isso que eu gostaria de
dizer hoje para cada mulher e criança
que foi vítima de violência de qualquer
tipo não foi sua culpa não foi só a
roupa não foi o que você disse
não foi o que você fez você é a vítima
não foi sua culpa nunca foi sua culpa e
é por isso que eu vim aqui hoje para
contar essa história pra vocês em honra
a essas a voz a essas mães a essas
mulheres e o que eu peço hoje é que
vocês conheçam essas histórias
procurem saber com seus familiares na
internet
as bibliotecas ou então perguntem pra
nós indígenas
nós estamos nas aldeias mas estamos nas
cidades também nós somos artistas
blogueiro escritores professores
universitários
nós aprendemos até mesmo a falar a sua
língua para que vocês pudessem nos ouvir
o que eu preciso hoje
fez nos ouçam nós estamos aí do seu lado
e nós precisamos que você esteja do
nosso lado para que nós possamos seguir
vivos nos ouça o simples ato de nos
ouvir será revolucionário e pode mudar a
história não era tendo aí
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]